so going back to my theory that you know
you become you know an acceptable guy in
terms of the in-crowd was it you you
would tell me about Bill Gates and then
you said to me oh yeah right was that
all about well on Bill Gates's last day
of work Bill Gates the guy who invented
basically well he started Microsoft yeah
at Microsoft his last day I roasted him
Oh his last day at Microsoft they say to
you would you come and roast him yeah
and I said is this what you want a real
roast you know or this is this light
roast a toast right no a roast even the
invitation said Rose okay
and it's just you roasting it was me and
a lot of famous people roasting him but
mostly people from Microsoft but it was
Warren Buffett oh wow um who else uh
Steve Ballmer was there uh it was it was
who I know who Steve Ballmer is but of
course he's playing to everyone he owns
the Clippers ok guys you know Steve
Ballmer owns the Clippers
yeah right right right yes so anyway it
was a disaster it was an absolute I mean
it he did not first of all I insisted
that he be on stage with me if I was
going to do this because the key to a
roast is that the people in the audience
see that he's a cookie laughing yes well
unfortunately the roast he was not
laughing oh my god not even a little bit
who did you say - who said to you that
that he wants to be roasted were you
having a direct conversation with him he
did I mean no it wasn't a direct
conversation I mean he agree he knew it
wasn't a surprise right maybe he didn't
know what exactly a roast was oh my god
you because listen you got to know
yourself when it's a roast they say
horrible things about you right and and
they're all basically true right so you
gotta just [ __ ] take it but I I don't
get roasted because I can't take it I
have a thin skin well neither could Bill
Gates Wow at the at the end of it he
said I want to thank the comedian the
comedian comedian
Oh like we couldn't get Jay Leno for
this
say did you go over to him and say
listen no I was I was furious at the end
of the at the end of the night you were
yeah oh yeah because you because he
wasn't laughing did you bomb oh yeah Oh
only person laughing was Steve Ballmer
and he was laughing like a maniac did
anyone take it away made it worse than
yet did anyone pay they had like five
cameras shooting this though I think
you've got I think the tapes have been
destroyed if Microsoft wants to go into
the streaming business all they have to
do it oh my god you must have been
flipping out I had one of my jokes was
what did you say about gates got a 1580
on the SAT the only reason he didn't get
a perfect score is because one of the
questions was what does a vagina look
like that's funny and he's not laughing
at that Oh